khloe kardashian is speaking out after a
commenter called her out on social media
claiming coco has quote so much plastic
surgery
some advice is great but it's also not
what you say it's how you say it
it all went down after the 36 year old
reality star
recently retweeted this commercial she
shot for a migraine medication
i just heard something amazing now for
the first time
one medication was approved to treat and
prevent
migraines shortly after coco shared the
clip
one commenter said she looked like she
had quote so much plastic surgery
adding that she quote looked like an
alien and attributed this
to chloe's frequent migraines well chloe
wasn't having it
and responded to the tweet quote sorry
you feel that way
you have every right to block mute me i
am trying to help many out there who
suffer in silence
the good american founder added that the
commenter was entitled to their opinion
but noted that she doesn't think they
should refer to themselves as a feminist
if they are quote
attacking a woman unprovoked
of course this isn't the first time
chloe has spoken out after someone
publicly commented on her appearance
back in february chloe responded to
critics who claimed her good american
campaign photos were heavily
photoshopped
after seeing her super stretched out
fingers and feet
isn't that crazy chloe chimed in
tweeting that the whole thing had her
quote
cracking up explaining that the camera
lens they used
elongates objects that are close to the
camera and
last year after someone slid into the
comments on this pic of chloe and her
daughter true
writing who is that on the right the
proud mom clapped back
and dropped the mic writing your new
stepmother
be nice or get grounded i'm gonna figure
it all out i promise you we're all
all gonna learn in april chloe got
candid about her appearance when a
leaked photo in a bikini surfaced
which she attempted to have taken down
at the time she wrote on instagram that
she has struggled with body image her
whole life
and had quote every right to ask for it
not to be shared
coco concluded her post writing quote i
have realized that we cannot continue to
live life trying to fit into the perfect
mold of what others have set for us
just do you and make sure your heart is
happy
she then went live on instagram dancing
around to ariana grande's song
pov showing off her toned physique
and all this echoes what chloe told et
back in 2019
beauty starts from the inside i really
think i'm in a good place but i think
working on your personal growth
internally is something that will be a
forever
mission and i always want to evolve and
grow and mature
emotionally because that's how we become
better people